so what is top down communication and if
you read all the books and articles
about that you will find out that there
are lots of definitions many people
claiming different things to be down
communication so I really want to
simplify it for you so in my experience
what this really comes down to is two
things namely first in your
communication to focus on the results to
focus on the content to only focus on
the things that really matter to your
audience and second always starting your
communication with the key message with
the key result that you want to
communicate to your audience and the
main error that many people do is not
starting with this result with this key
message but rather starting with all the
individual details with all the little
arguments that when your whole case is
composed of and then only in the very
end to then draw the conclusion from it
so they pretty much turn the pyramid
around and this for many different
reasons is not considered effective
communication